[Music]
next question
thank you
so the next question is what does
malachi 4 verse 2 mean about us growing
up as
calves of the stall so malachi 4 verse 2
says
but unto you that fear my name shadow's
righteousness arise with healing in his
wings and you should forth and grow up
as cows of the stall all right a simple
when christ when we die let's say i'm
about six feet tall when i rise
i'll be six feet tall
but originally according to ellen white
adam was about twice the height of men
living today so something has to change
when the son of righteousness arises
with healing these rings even in the new
world things will change in us we will
grow back to the original stature we had
if you read revelation 22 verses 1 and 2
and he showed me a pure river of water
of life clear as crystal proceeding out
of the throne of god and of the lamb in
the midst of the street of it on an eye
the side of the river was there the tree
of life
of the street was there a tree of life
which beared twelve man of fruit and
yielded the fruit every month and the
leaves of the tree were for the healing
of the nation changes will take place
over time as we live in this perfect
world we don't die six feet and rise 15
feet we come up and physical changes
take place what changes immediately in
the grave is we're no longer able to die
but our stature will change you know
whatever else needs to come to the
original perfection that will happen
over time and so he shall go forth and
grow up as calves of the soul so that is
what is meant by that
the literal growing up because in the
eyes of god right now all of us are
midgets and i say use that word
respectfully we are small
you know when adam sees how small we are
he'll probably collapse and in shame and
shock because when he died people were
still his size
but after the flood the size of the
human race declined rapidly along with
the length of life
in the new world we shall grow grow grow
grow grow
in uh our eternal life with christ
thank you what's the third part of that
question the third part is will we
remember loved ones yes
i shall be known even as also i am known
first corinthians 13. so yes we shall
know a lot once of course